bonjour à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue avec aujourd'hui vous allez le
découvrir un plateau exceptionnel pour
parler de l'actualité du moment je vous
propose de découvrir tout de suite en
images le sommaire de notre émission
notre dame des landes ce feuilleton qui
n'en finit pas ça fait cinquante ans que
ça dure et un ultime rapport a été remis
au premier ministre va-t-il en tirer
pour autant des conclusions et bien on
va essayer de se pencher sur ce sujet
nous allons aussi revenir sur l'élection
de laurent wauquiez à la tête des
républicains c'était dimanche dernier
mais on va se focaliser cette fois sur
son programme ses propositions en
économie mais pas seulement pour voir
l'écho qu'elles peuvent rencontrer dans
l'opinion nous allons aussi parler de
donald trump dont le candidat
républicain ron moore a subi une défaite
cuisante au sénat fragilisant ainsi le
président des états unis
et puis nous allons parler du loup les
loups sont de plus en plus nombreux en
france ils sont pas encore entrés dans
paris mais il s'en rapproche
faut-il du coup les éliminer la
polémique fait rage et nous en parlerons
avec quatre invités qui sont autour de
cette table bonjour adélaïde
zulfikarpasic vous êtes la directrice de
bva opinion institutions d'âge bien
connus
on sent lucile schmid co-président de la
fondation verte européenne tout le monde
connaît désormais votre dernier livre la
france résiste-t-elle à l'écologie aux
éditions du bord de l'eau c'était en
2016 bonsoir alexis lacroix
vous êtes directeur délégué de la
rédaction de l'express
votre excellent magazine sort en
couverture ce week-end de johnny une vie
rock'n'roll ce formidable parce que vous
continuez à rendre hommage à johnny
hallyday je veux dire que on voit dans
votre magazine des choses qu'on n'avait
pas lu ailleurs et donc ça c'était pas
tant que merci beaucoup et bonsoir
renaud girard
vous êtes le chroniqueur international
du figaro on retrouve vos analyses
chaque mardi dans le meilleur quotidien
du monde et vous est aussi l'auteur de
quel diplomatie pour la france prendre
les réalités telles qu'elles sont c'est
paru aux éditions du cerf
il y a quelques semaines nous commençons
avec notre dame des landes
mission de médiation avait été lancé le
1er juin dernier sur ce sujet par le
président de la république et les
médiateurs après six mois de travail 200
auditions et 63 pages ont rendu leur
rapport pour dire eh ben pour dire rien
c'est à dire que c'est tout pouvoir de
trancher et il ne se prononcent pas
entre les deux
dans l'alternative faut-il construire un
nouvel aéroport à notre dame des landes
ou simplement aménagé celui qui existe
déjà
est-ce qu'on se moque du monde du 6
schmid côté guillaume je suis pas
d'accord avec ce que vous dites sur le
fait qu'on ne dit rien c'est à dire que
je pense que ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on fait retomber la pression
parce que ça fait plus d'une quarantaine
d'années qu'on dit qu'il faut faire cet
aéroport et qu'on ne le fait pas et que
entre temps c'est comme pour le loup
d'ailleurs les camps se sont structurés
et qui a les anti aéroport qui sont
parfois assez violent et il ya aussi une
forme de détermination jean marc ayrault
lui même a repris position sur
l'aéroport d'une façon légèrement
ridicule j'allais dire il ya une
focalisation sur ce sujet alors qu'il
s'agit quand même de savoir si on
agrandit ou pas ou si on bouge ou pas à
l'aéroport de nantes
donc moi je trouve que c'est bien que
les experts aient fait des mois
d'auditions et qui propose deux
scénarios
on pourrait dire il aurait dû trancher
sauf qu'il faut se rappeler qu emmanuel
macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle a dit au fond je serais
plutôt l'aéroport puis ensuite à nommer
une médiation avec des personnes qui
sont neutres mais pour dont certaines
sont plutôt défavorables aéroports mais
qui ont pris au gras qui est proche de
zéro gérard feldzer est assez proche de
nicolas hulot et on sait que nicolas
hulot est contre l'aéroport donc moi je
trouve que ce qui est intéressant et je
le dis vraiment de façon sincère c'est
que s'il ne tranche pas ils disent que
les deux options sont raisonnables c'est
à dire qu'ils amènent à mon avis les
partisans dans chaque camp à se dire il
ya quelque chose qui doit se dérouler de
manière raisonnable après ce que je vais
dire franchement aussi c'est que je
regrette qu'on se remet toujours un
homme providentiel qu'il faille aller
jusqu'au président de la république pour
trancher en janvier mais si ces
tranchées si on enterre 43 ans de débats
pourquoi pas avoir fait un rapport qui
propose deux scénarios
et puis un référendum est effectivement
vous le disiez à l'instant la pression
d'un public c'est promis va prendre sa
décision
encore quelques semaines de patience le
premier ministre l'a dit tout à l'heure
quand on lui remettait le rapport le
rapport nous invite à réfléchir sur un
choix qui se formaliserait plutôt de la
façon suivante notre dame des landes où
un réaménagement de l'aéroport de nantes
atlantique
un certain nombre de vérifications sur
des éléments techniques qui y sont
mentionnés dans ce rapport seront
conduites très rapidement de façon à
permettre au gouvernement
de prendre avant la fin du mois de
janvier comme s'y est engagé le
président de la république une décision
alexis lacroix ce que vous avez un point
de vue sur cette question faut-il ou non
un nouvel aéroport
moi je pense si vous voulez que je ne
suis pas de dons le camp de ceux qui de
satanisme a priori ce projet d'aéroport
dans cette partie disons plutôt
campagnard du nord du département de la
loire atlantique néanmoins vous le
disiez ça fait 40 ans au fond que le
feuilleton dure ça devient un peu
ridicule vos diverses raisons qui nous
appartient pas ici de condamner elles
existent voilà il ya une mobilisation
politique autour de cet aéroport qui
excède largement les purs milieux
environnementalistes pour diverses
raisons
ça paraît difficile à faire donc je
crois que la sagesse de la part de
macron et d'edouard philippe sas kdh en
tenir compte et peut-être d'orienter
leur apport dans vers le vert le sens
d'un renoncement à cette à ce nouvel
aéroport est plutôt d'une extension de
des deux aéroports qui existe déjà
voilà ce que je bouge je ne suis pas
expert en la matière donc c'est un point
de vue vraiment de citoyens nous ont
informés mais il me semble que quand il
ya tellement de résistance contre un
projet qui a été historiquement retoqué
40 fois et qu'on leur on voit le
remettre sur le tapis dans l'espoir d'
ailleurs on sait pas pourquoi de de
faire ce comment dire ceux de se
dissoudre les oppositions qui
entre-temps d'ailleurs se sont se sont
figés je pense que il a toutes les
chances de ne pas aboutir
on devrait en tirer les conséquences
aujourd'hui au sommet de l'exécutif et
faire une croix définitivement sur notre
dame des landes
adélaïde zulfikarpasic alors être un
point de vue sur ce sujet il ya là deux
qu'ils ont plutôt pour l'abandon là mais
vous n'êtes pas obligés de voter non
j'ai plutôt bien prononcé du point de
vue de l'opinion
aujourd'hui si on regarde les français
je pense qu'ils sont relativement
éloigné du sujet par des gens qui
habitent dans la région d'ailleurs on
s'aperçoit que plus on est proche de la
de la zone puis on est opposé pour son
éloigne plus on est pour ou on est assez
indifférent donc pour l'instant à
l'opinion elle et il n'y a pas vraiment
de risque dans l'opinion
en revanche quelle que soit la décision
qui sera prise il y aura forcément des
mécontents
il faut voir ce que les mécontents quel
poids ils peuvent avoir et dans quelle
mesure ils peuvent agiter un petit peu
un drapeau rouge et
traîner des remous il ya deux choses par
rapport à mayol macron la première chose
c'est que tout d'abord il va trancher
janvier et donc ça va venir un peu
nourrir sa posture qui est effectivement
tête de l'homme providentiel mais c'est
l'homme qui tranche qui tient des
défunts qui prend des décisions qui
tient ses engagements on ça va venir un
peu alimenté son moulin de john ford va
sortir du rang même temps là pour le
coup oui il va sortir en même temps mais
donc après effectivement dans le en même
temps il ya deux alternatives soit
effectivement il prend cette décision de
renoncer et d'une part il a ainsi
soutenir son ministre nicolas hulot qui
est lui aussi et pour le renoncement
d'autre part il vient montrer qu' il a
pas seulement des beaux discours en
matière d'écologie il est pas seulement
pour organiser des climats des sommets
sur le climat mais qu'il a des vraies
convictions et il s'y tient en même
temps c'est marc qui vient en faisant ça
il fait fi du de la consultation qui a
eu lieu il s'assoit un petit peu sur
sept ce référendum il ya eu un
référendum qui est organisée uniquement
dans le département la valoir avec qui
et 55 % des gens ont voté pour dont ça
veut dire un petit peu que c'est un
homme qui est au dessus de la démocratie
et qui n'écoutent pas les citoyens et l
inverse il décide de maintenir le projet
ils abîment son image écolo indécente
en revanche il apparaît comme celui qui
écoute les citoyens donc effectivement
dans un cas comme dans l'autre il ya un
risque politique en tout cas en terme
d'image pour lui c'est ce qui est
intéressant enfin tac au tac mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'au moment où le
référendum a eu lieu il ya une critique
assez nourris certes de spécialistes de
juriste mais assez nourris sur les
conditions d'organisation du référendum
et notamment le fait que les questions
d'information les délais la procédure
donc c'est vrai que c'est un référendum
qui a été critiquée d'emblée après avec
moi ce que j'allais dire c'est que sur
ce sujet de la démocratie qui est un
sujet essentiel parce qu'il faut
articuler démocratie et écologie arrêté
d'en faire un sujet d'experts on voit
bien que la forme démocratique habituel
n'est pas évidente pour faire entendre
les choses par exemple c'est un premier
ministre on parlait de manuel valls qui
a annoncé à la radio
au niveau national un référendum local
donc on voit bien que là dessus il ya un
problème d'articulation entre locales et
nationales et surtout si c'est emmanuel
macron qui va décider si on fait ou pas
un aéroport à nantes il ya quelque chose
là qui est de l'ordre du paradoxe qu'il
faut d'une manière ou d'une autre
résoudre et d'ailleurs c'est emmanuel
macron décide non il faudra qu'il
explique pourquoi il a fallu aller
jusqu'à lui sur ce sujet et alors au
figaro si on organise des référendum
puisque vous êtes appelés à voter sur ce
sujet faut-il renoncer à cette à ce
projet d'aéroport à notre dame des
landes
d'après les derniers comptages vous êtes
58% à être plutôt favorables nombre
défavorable bardon défavorable à la
construction de l'aéroport notre dame
des landes c'était un pointage effectué
à 17h01 renaud girard
faut-il renoncer à cet aéroport je pense
qu'il faut renoncer
c'est l'occasion de renoncer j'ai aucun
avis technique sur les reports ne me
suis pas un avis technique est ce qu'il
faut et l'art jir celui qui existe ou en
conçoit nouveau c'est pas la question et
je ne je ne connais pas les lieux non je
peux pas m'exprimer celles qui sont
croissants pour l'artiste c'est une
occasion c'est une occasion d'abandonner
ces référendums locaux je suis contre la
république référendaire non je pense que
c'est bon ça a permis en france
au général de gaulle de parme de deux
parties dans en beauté pour des
questions extrêmement importantes comme
les indépendances n'est pas l'algérie
c'était on peut concevoir les
référendums mais je pense je suis pour
la démocratie représentative
je regrette d'ailleurs beaucoup que les
anglais et ce alors à ne leur apporter
que du mal et renoncer à leur démocratie
traditionnelle qui la démocratie
parlementaire la chambre des communes
depuis huit neuf siècles et qu'ils aient
adopté cette pratique référendaire qui
était utilisé par cameron dans des
tactiques politiciennes et là elle a ça
me chagrine parce que si on organise un
référendum
je suis content je trouve qu'on devrait
abandonner ses histoires de de
référendum parce que ce sont des
questions techniques et qu' il ya des
représentants élus pour étudier ces
questions mais
une fois que le référendum s'est
prononcée et la f1 en faveur de cet
aéroport
c'est un déni de démocratie est
incroyable de revenir là dessus
alors il faut voilà donc donc voila
voila mon ami mon avis il ya eu un
référendum
les écologistes ont perdu qu'on
construise ceux se ses terres au poids
d'antoine lampes mais je dire je n'ai
pas tout à fait compris pourquoi le
héros était si favorable j'imagine que
c'est pour des raisons de développement
du tourisme et pourquoi pas dans sa
région
est-ce que ce référendum serait
tellement plus polluants que celui qui
existe aujourd'hui je reprends la parole
d'abord qu'on salue et les internautes
qui nous rejoignent pour saluer génie
qui se demandent pourquoi le dossier de
notre dame des landes est devenu un
dossier national et non plus seulement
d'une ville
et puis paulette qui se demandent
pourquoi ne pas développer l'aéroport
existant de nantes afin de préserver la
nature
je voudrais rajouter une pièce au
dossier on va écouter cécile duflot
alors l'ancien ministre du logement est
aussi une écologiste convaincue donc
elle est plutôt elle est même carrément
contre le projet national des langues ça
c'est pas une surprise en revanche ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle dit
que dès que les micros sont fermés
presque tout le responsable politique
eux aussi sont contre ce projet écoutez
la aucun responsable politique de
premier plan aucun nous défendons of
notre dame des landes tout le monde sait
que c'est un projet absurde
l'obstination c'est pas un signe
d'autorité
l'autorité c'est de faire des choses
justes et de se donner les moyens de
prendre des décisions justes de le
chantage à la virilité de dire attention
on va voir c'est un test pour emmanuel
macron est ce qu'il aura le courage
d'imposer cet aéroport sinon ça veut
dire qui sera qui va se déballonner a
laissé libre à vous confirmer c'est vrai
que la plupart des responsables
politiques sont plutôt contre quand les
micros sont éloquents c'était mon
sentiment ma position d'ailleurs qui est
plutôt disons hostiles à à la conclusion
de ce projet
comment dire encore une fois pluri
décennale 1 qui datent bien plusieurs
décennies donc je crois de l'année
soixante dix huit au départ donc c'est
visiblement quand quelque chose ne se
fait pas c'est comme une rencontre
amoureuse un si beau si ça ne se fait
pas c'est pas la peine de poursuivre sur
l'aca va pas quand sur une voie là où le
résumé vient la sagesse populaire mais
ça m'étonne pas cibler que la plupart
des responsables publics au fond sont
gênés et sont gênés aux entournures par
ce dossier
ils sont bien que il est mal engagée et
puis pour répondre sur la question
référendaire
c'est drôle j'écoutais avec beaucoup
tour comme toujours beaucoup d'intérêt
mon camarade renaud girard
je pense exactement l'inversé de lui et
je pense que le référendum dans ce dans
ce cas là il a été conçu comme une sorte
de d'armes de réduction des dégâts de la
technicité politique autrement dit pour
le dire autrement c'est une manière de
dire voyez on est proche de vous on
s'intéresse à votre avis mais je pense
en revanche qu'il ne doit pas avoir
force de loi sert qui ne peut pas
remplacer une décision ceci vous
consulte pour rire quand vous commencez
vous à ne pas qu'on ne voyait pas le
construire on est con sable ggv
m'entourent on arrête
j'aurais juste pour suivre mon
raisonnement je pense que c'est une
photographie de l'opinion
il est évidemment légitime de le faire
encore une fois dans un contexte où il
faut lutter contre cette coupure des
élites et du peuple
en tout cas théorisée par beaucoup y
compris d'ailleurs récemment dans un
livre qui avait fait l'événement par
l'ancien conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
patrick buisson
donc pour toutes ces raisons oui pour le
référendum mais en revanche le
référendum est une photographie de
l'opinion
il ne saurait se substituer à la
décision politique et pour finir avec se
laver faire un homme consulta
consultatif et pour finir les votations
comme en suisse c'est mon sentiment
entre la votation comme moi je suis
contre les votations commencé et enfin
un coup de chaud et enfin point sur du
flou chez d'accord avec le fond de la
position je suis moins d'accord en
revanche avec l'attak contre la commande
hier le test le pseudo test de virilité
qui serait fait à macron il faudra bien
qu'une décision soit prise et je loin de
moi l'idée de valoriser la république
césarienne ou le disions la confiscation
du pouvoir tels que sa carrière telle
que la 5
voilà la confiscation jupitérienne du
pouvoir tels que la 5e pole exacerbée en
revanche il faudra bien que quelqu'un
soit là pour dénouer
me mauvais de cette crise et ça sera
probablement le président de la
république
si j'avais un conseil à lui donner je
suis pas son conseiller si j'avais un
conseil à lui donner ce serait
effectivement de rétropédaler avec
habileté mais je que je trouve sur la
question du courage c'est que une
certaine façon cécile duflot dit qu'il
faudrait enfin la question du courage
pour être invoquées pour ne pas se
déballonner je crois qu'il faut du
courage dans les deux cas parce que
comme je le disais il ya deux camps donc
moi je trouve que si macron a du courage
bon voilà c'est bien et on va pas dire
d'un côté c'est le courage et de l'autre
côté c'est la lâcheté il ya tranché
quelque chose que personne n'a tranché
depuis 40 ans ça c'est un point
important et je voulais juste faire un
truc par rapport à la question de la
virilité et sais c'est que je ne sais
pas si c'est un problème de virilité
mais il ya un sujet où quand on était un
grand élu local il ya trente ans
quarante ans on construisait son
aéroport où on essayait d'avoir son
aéroport où son autoroute où son tgv et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est en
cause c'est vraiment un changement une
transformation de la mentalité des
grands élus locaux sur la question
écologique on voit bien ce que fait anne
hidalgo on voit bien ce que fait
l'ancien maire de new york il ya quelque
chose qui se modifie aussi sur la
manière de dire on pèse et c'est en
transformant ce qu'on appelle la
technique du grand projet que certains
qualifient d' inutile
moi je pense que cet aéroport
aujourd'hui est inutile et mais ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est qu'on peut
le trouver inutile pour des raisons
écologiques pour des raisons économiques
également parce qu'on peut penser qu'on
prendra demain - l'avion qu'un autre
mode de transport et donc il ya aussi
des arguments il ya quarante ans qu'on
n'utilisait pas on pensait pas la nature
par exemple on pensait pas qu'on allait
faire bouger des agriculteurs donc il ya
des choses nouvelles
sans vouloir être trop longue adélaïde
zulfikarpasic on parlait de courage en
tout cas
il faudrait du courage emmanuel macron
pour maintenir ce projet parce que ils
auraient contre lui le ministre le plus
populaire du gouvernement
nicolas hulot ça c'est un risque
politique majeur il aurait contre lui le
ministre effectivement le plus populaire
du gouvernement mais à mon sens c'est
pas ça le risque le plus important pour
lui c'est le décalage entre l'image qui
essaie d'imprimer dans l'opinion avec
mes cocos planète great games et le
sommet qui vient d'organiser ça donnera
une espèce de dissonance entre il ya ce
que je dis est ce que je fais est à mon
sens ce serait plus là le risque
politique et pour répondre à la question
qui a été posée tout à l'heure je crois
comme le rapport laisse entendre mais
vous corrigerez que quand même des deux
alternatives en termes de bilan car mode
bas carbone c'est le retrait du projet
qui s'est quand même préférable pour
tout dire c'est par hasard s'il ya en
même temps ce sommet
sur le climat et puis la remise de l as
raison ali c'est vrai qu'on ne dans ce
débat on al'impression s'ils voulaient
que les au fond la question écologique
la question du souci de notre
environnement du souci légitime un sert
pas la deep ecology pas là bas pas la
folie intégristes de certains d'une
certaine écologie nordiques mais
l'écologie française à la hulot disons 1
passe au second plan comme s'il y avait
un affrontement entre deux visions
quelque sorte économiques de la future
région la glagla la grolle la future
grande région bretagne entre ceux qui
pensent que c'est bon pour l'économie de
la loire atlantique et ceux qui sont
plutôt pour une extension des aéroports
mais on oublie l'essentiel c'est que ça
va bouffer si on fait cet aéroport dans
le nord de la loire atlantique
ça bouge entre 50 et 100 kilomètres
carrés de campagne c'est pas rien mais
louise d'un hectare à peu près je crois
voilà donc 110 à 180 c c'est énorme et
caves sachant qu'en plus ça génère aussi
une urbanisation périphérique autour de
l'aéroport dans des petites villes qui
vont se développer et c'est pourquoi pas
c'est peut-être bien pour la croissance
il n'empêche que pour l'écologie ça
l'est moins et les poches on le sait les
poches de campagne se réduisent de plus
en plus il ya une bétonisation accéléré
faut réfléchir avant de lancer un tel
investissement
et bah bon courage monsieur le président
sa part 10 secondes chamoin juste une
roma a fait 18 kilomètres carrés non
mais c'est parce que j'ai fait des
études de maths à l'époque j'ai fait
n'est pas contradictoire fait que ce
qu'on avait des pores qu'on la promesse
que c'était de cannes hectares et celles
à l'ancienne a déclaré 100 mètres sur
100 m jaune akouala d'accord et donc et
donc mille huit cent mille 800 ha ça
fait dix-huit kilomètres cas et c'est
tout absolument et dernier toujours
sympa ça veut dire que voilà donc et il
ya toujours 50 % de ce qui les regarde
c'est juste débattent qui sont contre la
construction de cet aéroport
je propose de parler de passer à un
autre sujet qui n'a rien à voir laurent
wauquiez vous le savez a été élu
dimanche assez largement le président de
la république président du parti des
républicains depuis la polémique fait
rage pour savoir est-ce qu'il est trop à
droite pas assez à droite il ya un
sondage assez intéressant qui a été
publié
sur ce sujet danger nos confrères de la
tribune aujourd'hui c'est un sondage bva
opinion
et donc je me tourne vers vous adélaïde
qu'est ce qu'ils disent long d'âge
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il dit deux
choses qui soit peut-être un peu
contradictoire il ya une majorité de
français qui trouvent que wauquiez trop
à droite mais une majorité relative
parce que si on additionne ceux qui
trouvent que c'est juste à droite comme
il faut sur l'immigration ou sur ou sur
la politique sociale
ceux qui trouvent que c'est comme il
faut ce qu'ils trouvent que c'est pas
assez à droite ça fait un peu plus oui
vous avez raison mais surtout à ce qu'il
soit intéressant c'est de voir comment
il est perçu par son socle électoral à
faire par les sympathisants et l'air
parce que le gros sujet du moment tout
le monde dit au lendemain de son
élection l'enjeu pour laurent wauquiez
c'est le rassemblement vers la question
je suis pas sûr tout cela finalement
l'enjeu pour lui de rassembler puisqu'on
voit qu'on a une large majorité de
sympathisants a l'air plus 75% qui ont
ils sont contents de cette victoire qui
ont une bonne image de lui et qui eux
sur ces son programme en tout cas de ce
qu'ils en connaissent en termes
d'économies de lutte contre le chômage
de contrôler les aides sociales nous
disent majoritairement ce que ce qu'ils
proposent et comme il faut en phase en
adéquation avec la ligne du parti et y
compris sur la migration vous avez 47 %
qui me disent c'est comme il faut et
vous avez un tiers des sympathisants
aient l'air qui me disent c'est pas
assez à droite donc leurs proches du
socle électoral n'est pas sur un manque
de fermeté mais peut-être même sur un
manque d'affirmation y compris sur la
question de l'immigration
quand on sait par ailleurs quand on
interroge les sympathisants 1ère sur
leurs préoccupations les questions
d'immigration de sécurité restent dans
leur trio de tête avec les questions
économiques donc à mon sens ce que nous
dit ce sondage est que sur la ligne sur
la ligne que doit emprunter laurent
wauquiez il est plutôt sur la bonne voie
et que la tentation du rassemblement le
conduira peut-être un espèce de grand
écart et qui le conduirait a opté pour
une ligne un peu tiède et que peut-être
cette question du rassemblement c'est
pas la bonne et qui doit tracer son
sillon sur ce qu'il est jusqu'à présent
et la plaine droite qui assume qui
s'assume qui assume ses valeurs et c'est
peut-être ça finalement
ce vers quoi il doit attendre quitte à
perdre un peu d des plumes au passage et
certains électeurs mais je pense que ce
serait assez
minoritaire et comme point de vue et une
imagination est une émission en partant
qui prône la démocratie participative
vous êtes à nouveau appelés à vous
prononcer vaud qui a t'il la bonne
stratégie
vous vous prononcez sur twitter hashtag
figaro live #primaires pour l'instant
vous êtes 68% à trouver que non il n'a
pas la bonne stratégie et vous alexis
lacroix qu'en pensez vous alors je suis
d'accord avec la photographie
qu'adélaïde fait du sondage c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ce dont témoigne ce
sondage c'est que le socle le soc sa
base disons électorale pour son triomphe
de dimanche soir est en phase avec lui
et d'ailleurs cela corrobore tout ce
qu'on a pu dire depuis maintenant une
petite dizaine d'années sur la
droitisation de l'électorat l air
patrick buisson dont on peut par
ailleurs contesté les orientations
semblent oui mais il avait raison oui
mais il avait raison depuis son il ya un
point sur lequel il avait raison c'était
de dire à sarkozy quand il le
conseillait c'était de lui dire
attention nicolas tu dois prendre en
compte le fait que tes électeurs ta base
électorale au sein de la droite hausse
ne sont plus à droite qu'avant ça c'est
non mais je voulais la spécificité des
arguments de buissons historiquement ces
dessins alors buisson mais plus le
conseiller de vos cuisses qui lui
reproche de l'avoir lâché dans la sphère
des enregistrements en revanche il ya un
autre homme qui a pris la place et qui a
une analyse sensiblement proche et donc
le sondage nous oblige à la valider
c'est le fameux que spécialiste de la
carte électorale
ange sitbon que le grand public est en
train de découvrir et ce monsieur y
pense ce monsieur il pense comme lui
sont qu'effectivement le peuple de
droite est plus à droite qu'avant et que
donc un responsable public qui envisage
de se présenter à la présidentielle sous
les couleurs de la droite doit
correspondre à ceux à celle comment dire
à ce décalage vers la droite du public
donc je pense qu'effectivement de ce
point de vue là adelaida raison la
question du rassemblement n'est pas
prioritaire aujourd'hui et ça valide
plutôt la stratégie actuelle de vos
pieds mais attention
mais attention il ya une deuxième manche
vous savez bien guillaume qu une
présidentielle ça se prépare très en
amont et pour l'instant c'est mon
opinion de commentateurs pour l'instant
le couloir qui est choisie qui est à
coup a évidemment à court terme
victorieux en raison de la sociologie
électorale de la droite mais il est
probablement le son centre de gravité
est probablement beaucoup peut être trop
à droite pour emporter l'adhésion des
français voilà bien vu que leur désir
principal aujourd'hui est un désir de
centre-droit donc attention est scanné
doigts et potentiellement est ce qu'un
edouard philippe ou un françois baroin
requinquer n'aurait pas plus de chance
de l'emporter lors d'une confrontation
présidentielle face à emmanuel macron le
cilss finesse que laurent wauquiez dont
je sais que vous êtes proche
politiquement à la bonne stratégie avant
cérium ailleurs je ne connais pas vous
appuyez de nos politiques pas du tout
vous ne connaissez absolument pas cher
guillaume non moi je pense que c'est une
chose de gagner un parti politique est
une autre chose de gagner une élection
excusez moi le rappeler ce principe très
simple à utiliser et et je pense avoir
fait ce feuilleton est donc là il ya une
première chose c'est ça la deuxième
chose c'est quand même de constater que
tout le monde ne peut pas rassembler
qu'emmanuel macron a lancé un espèce de
rassemblement en même temps de droite et
de gauche et que ya pas deux personnes
qui peuvent le faire sur le champ
politique donc à l'évidence celui qui
rassemble aujourd'hui c'est emmanuel
macron et je pense que laurent wauquiez
dont je ne suis pas proche politiquement
et scoop a eu au moins la bonne analyse
stratégique de se dire ben moi il faut
que je rassemble moncan le noyau dur
donc ça je trouve que c'est très bien vu
après je ne suis pas sûr que ça lui
donne un socle électoral puissant et en
fait il faut regarder ce que ça donnera
aux prochaines échéances par exemple
européenne en 2019 ou à des élections
locales ou à des élections partielles
moi je dirai juste une chose c'est que
on sent chez laurent wauquiez que toute
cette droitisation contrairement
peut-être à patrick buisson que vous
aimez site et ça repose sur une forme
d'opportunisme
on sent que c'est une volonté de gagner
une forme d'opportunisme donc il reste à
ce qu'ils nous convaincre de sa
sincérité sarkozy quand il était causé
par le stress et rêve c'est pareil
contradictoires qu'il irait sas qui nous
convainquent de sa sincérité par des
positions peut-être plus davantage de
contenu parce que là il ya beaucoup de
principes mais il faudra montrer que
c'est opérationnel
pas encore géré son programme renaud
girard vous dis moi je pense que vous
avez 12 secondes
la vision parce que je pars toujours
d'années donc c'est plus difficile à
sous sont fortes et station la vision le
panorama de la politique française
tel que je le vois mais je suis plutôt
spécialiste de politique internationale
d'abord la critique de macron d'abord lé
fait pas mélenchon donc une vraie
critique de gauche qui existent en dix
ans à 7,1 c'est le maquereau le
président des riches etc
et puis vous avez donc macro qui a
considérablement réunit le centre et le
centre droit français c'est une sorte de
giscard si vous voulez et qui peut être
va faire deux mandats
ensuite vous voulez avoir une offre
politique de droite qui n'est pas celle
de juppé parce qu'on fait tous les jupes
et son avec m'accrocher monsieur mâcon
même au pouvoir n'est ce pas mon premier
ministre qu'on a vu d'autres c'est à moi
ils sont au pouvoir bon alors lui mais
c'est le son dernier credo c'est faire
un peu comme je dirais le parti
républicain américain et qu'il montrera
des opérations avec l'étranger
c'est-à-dire d'aller très à droite comme
le tea party qui est très à droite non
plus à droite que le que le front
national l'aide en france vu ça va du
tea party aux bushiste lambda le parti
républicain américain et donc c'est le
créneau mon avis qui reste politique à
monsieur wauquiez est évidemment quand
on dit qu'il veut s'allier
il peut pas s'allier avec marine le pen
parce qu'il ya chez marine le pen un
côté très à gauche sur les aides
sociales etc
c'est son côté philippe auquel peut
peut-être essayer d'abandonner en ce
moment elle n'a eu beaucoup pendant la
campagne
donc en revanche on peut imaginer que
vous qui veut faire un grand parti de
droite où il irait récupérer tous ses
électeurs marion maréchal-le pen donc
qu'ils sont plutôt conservateurs sur les
moeurs et mais qui reste en matière
économiques libéraux à la française
c'est à dire pour le capitalisme est une
entreprise privée
voilà donc et donc on verra et alors on
verra on peut passeront peut pas dire on
verra ce que donne cette nouvelle offre
politique il est sûr que ça va pas trop
à ça raconte ça va être très difficile
c'est sûr c'est ce qui a pas trop mal
réussi à donald trump d'ailleurs lors
des états élections présidentielles
cette stratégie joséphine sur
lefigaro.fr nous dit est ce que
l'abstention a joué dans pour les sur
les résultats de l'élection les
républicains alors l'abstention c'était
quoi c'était l'abstention jeu peut-être
celle et chez les militants de mémoire
adélaïde zulfikarpasic la moitié c'est
ça à peu près des militants qui ont voté
oui un petit peu moins 49 cents 4 42%
après sa difficile de savoir
effectivement qu'est ce qui a motivé ce
qui a motivé l'abstention il faut quand
même garder en tête qu'on était à
l'issue d'une très longue séquence
électorale au cours de laquelle les
erreurs sinon beaucoup vu les français
on vous colle t y compris les
sympathisants à l'est républicain donc
elle va aussi sans doute une espèce de
lassitude c'est pas forcément un signe
de protestation
alors il voit juste la plupart internet
comme les choux été très facile même si
je pense que c'était peut-être de
l'indifférence ou durable mais je danse
largement ce que je voulais dire je suis
d'accord sur le fait que l'on gagne pas
une élection sur une ligne
aussi dur il va falloir rassembler que
laurent wauquiez sont pas le plus à même
de rassembler et pour moi il ya
effectivement quand même deux manches et
le parti dans un tel état peut-être pas
de délabrement c'est un peu fort mais en
tout cas doit se reconstruire et je
pense que pour se reconstruire
cette première étape elle est quand même
nécessaire surtout parce que vous l'avez
rappelé aujourd'hui c'est manioc de
mâcon qui est quelqu'un le rassemblement
est d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quand on interroge les
sympathisants à l'air sur ce qui pour
eux fait l'identité de leur parti il ya
deux jambes il ya une jambe plus tôt on
va dire au niveau des valeurs
conservatisme au niveau des valeurs et
une jambe qui est serait plutôt le
libéralisme économique
or pour eux les sympathisants à l'air
comme pour les français d'ailleurs dans
leur grande partie le libéralisme
économique
aujourd'hui il a incarné par emmanuel
macron donc laurent wauquiez quelque
part il avait eu tellement d'autre
option que d'aller se positionner sur
sur ce champ là remarque remarque
codicille pour employer une expression
que j'aime bien apostille à ce que vient
de dire ali à adelaïde c'est fondamental
à ce qu'elle dit est joué et moi
personnellement je craindrais qu'étant
donné le calcul qui est fait par vaux
qui en gros wauquiez triangulaire
entièrement d'accord avec renault
wauquiez triangulaire une partie de
l'extrême droite eurocompatible c'est à
dire en gros ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui chez les spécialistes du fn
la ligne marion marion maréchal-le pen
bon peut-être même la ligne nicolas bay
pour parler comme les spécialistes des
faits donc une ligne qui est à la fois
très traditionaliste et en même temps
eurocompatible entre 4 contre le disons
la version radicale de sortie de l'euro
qui était prônée par marine le pen et
qui prenait à l'extrême gauche par
mélenchon et en mai mais il risque et
risque dans ce grand écart parce que
s'ils voulaient c'est un grand écart les
les électeurs aient l'air même très
conservateur ils ne ils ne partagent pas
forcément les conceptions disons euros
libéral qu'il va être obligé de prôner
pour attirer à lui la frange marion il
ya un discours souverainiste qui est
extrêmement répandu
j'ai regardé sur le site du figaro de ce
matin les commentaires relatifs au fait
que l'un des parents la droite xavier
bertrand sur une mine plutôt disons de
centre-droit a quitté la rébellion eh
ben il ya plein de gens qui disent je
crois que c'est extrêmement significatif
bon débarras xavier va rejoindre tes
amis
dia liste mondialistes ça veut bien dire
que la pénétration du discours
souverainiste au radical au sein de l
air est important aujourd'hui est donc
wauquiez risque de se retrouver
tiraillé entre sa base électorale qui
est disons nez aux souverainistes si
vous voulez comme le rpr de jadis et
cette partie de l'extrême droite dillon
identité ont créé un kiki et plutôt
compatible c'est pas dit si c'était le
code civil tout ce que vous avez apporté
toutes ces annonces étaient développées
j'ai arrêté la cantine réserve non mais
je vous coupe la parole je crains pour
wauquiez un tiraillement gb je crois que
de l'avoir compris je suis sûr qu'il
prendra en compte votre inquiétude ça
m'étonnerait et votre crainte
parlons de donald trump on en avait
d'ailleurs déjà parlé pour comparer sa
stratégie avec celle de laurent wauquiez
sans doute ne connaissiez vous pas
monsieur doug jones
moi non plus en tout cas jusqu'à cette
nuit c'est un nouveau sénateur il est
démocrate et donc il a battu le candidat
de donald trump qui c'est important
cette élection parce que là la majorité
républicaine est assez courte elle est
même de plus en plus je crois qu'il n'y
a plus qu'une voix d'avancé pour les
républicains au sénat et donc le parti
de trump a échoué et pourtant le
président avait vraiment mouillé sa
chemise
écoutez le il était vendredi dernier en
meeting en floride
john un 10-0 paris nice et paris
c'était évidemment le slogan de campagne
donald trump ça voulait dire que le
président a nationalisé un peu cette
élection l'alabama voter classiquement
républicain et pourtant il a échoué
alors c'est une grosse oui c'est une
grave descente pour trump puisque contre
l'élection présidentielle contre hillary
clinton dont qu'il avait fait 66 % et
l'annoncé de l'êta dans cet amas pas je
pars là bas est dans cet état
le l'homme qu'il soutenait sderot moore
n'a fait que 48% contre 49% pour le
fameux d'aliose qui a donc été élu et
c'est mauvais pour 30 parce que vous
allez bientôt avoir les élections
intermédiaires donc en 2018 aux
etats-unis en novembre 2018 et vous
pouvez très bien donc on va on va
changer un tiers renouveler un tiers du
sénat et donc vous pouvez très bien
avoir la majorité du sénat qui ré de
l'autre côté ce qui empêcherait de
trame de faire toutes les réformes
fiscales qu'il veut faire il a commencé
à en faire parce qu'il faut rappeler
qu'il a en revanche la chambre des
représentants pour lui trump de manière
assez solide mais ça peut changer en
2018 et c'est assez c'est assez fâcheux
donc en fait c'est avoué c'est un vrai
revers pour pour lui est-ce que c'est dû
à sa politique à lui trump ou est-ce que
c'est dû au cas particulier de rob moore
qui donc est un homme atteint juge l'été
juge très à droite très anti immigrants
mais qui a été accusé dans cette
campagne d'avoir un double discours
c'est à dire faites ce que je dis mais
pas ce que je fait parce que il aurait
était convaincu faille à une plainte en
tout cas une plainte d'harcèlement
sexuel même presque de viol je crois
qu'entre de mais d'attendre contre des
jeunes filles mineures mais une affaire
qui date de plus de 30 ans et donc mais
je ne mets on ne sait pas encore demandé
un sondeur et est ce que c'est la
politique de trump elle même qui est
discrédité ou pas en tout cas je pense
que ça ne va rien changer et je ne pense
que trump ne va pas être un pitch
démocrate
toute la presse libérale américaine au
sens américain c'est-à-dire
progressistes du style etc a cru qu'il
pourrait y avoir un empêchement
c'est-à-dire destitution de trump je n'y
crois pas une seconde
il a il faut deux tiers des sénateurs
pour destituer et vous avez vu qui prend
des mesures de politique étrangère pour
élargir sa base électorale notamment
cette mesure de la reconnaissance de
jérusalem comme capitale de l'état
hébreu
ce qui lui permet tout consolider sa
base évangélique aux etats-unis tout en
gagnant des démocrates et vous avez vous
avez entendu les représentants
démocrates juif de new york à prouver
donald trump donc tout ça fait en sorte
que
oui et il va avoir sans doute des
difficultés au niveau du congrès du
parlement américain
mais je pense que donald trump va
pouvoir continuer de président jusqu'au
bout de son mandat alors la réélection
c'est trop tôt il était encore là il est
encore là pour quelques temps la
question à laquelle vous pouvez répondre
si vous souhaitez sur twitter c'est
quand est il responsable de la défaite
en alabama pour l'instant vous êtes 60 %
à considérer que oui renault gérard
faisait allusion à l'instant à la
politique fiscale du président des états
unis qui entend réduire les impôts y en
a un qui n'est pas d'accord et pourtant
des impôts doit en payer un petit peu
puisque c'est l'homme le plus riche du
monde
c'est bill gates le fondateur de
microsoft ils étaient ce matin chez nos
confrères d'rtl regarder dans la
mauvaise direction et des je pense que
parce que il faut qu un système
budgétaire un petit système fiscal créé
plus d'égalité plus progressif bon at
elle est une fille karpaty consent un
donald trump qui est un peu attaqué de
toutes parts ouais après je suis pas
spécialiste de l'opinion aux états unis
donc je pourrais je pourrais pas
vraiment répondre sur les causes en fait
de cette de cette défaite
les argumentations vous avez fait
laisserait plutôt entendre que c'est
peut-être le cas particulier de reuil
moore qui serait dans la balance puisque
vous avez dit pour élargir sa base
électorale et adressé justement à sa
base que sont les blancs évangélique
il a parlé notamment de enfin il a pris
cette décision de reconnaître jérusalem
comme capitale d'israël
or sa décision elle intervenue avant
l'élection si je ne me trompe pas en
alabama ses lapins nains une intox
justement très fort de blanc et vent
levé qui n'ont pas voté pour humour donc
ça plaiderait plutôt pour peut-être un
cas d'une campagne atypique avec une
personnalité qui a été remise en cause
pour des raisons de
des années de la plainte dont il a fait
l'objet maintenant voilà je sais pas
l'avenir nous dira si peu nombreux mais
plus globalement fragilisées ou s'il
encore s'est appuyé des soutiens
traditionnels au sein de l'opinion
américaine effectivement une partie des
républicains et est même favorable au
retrait de ron moore de la campagne
alexis lacroix très brièvement
je pense que bordeaux qui aura pas d'
impeachment je pense en revanche que le
processus qui a lieu aujourd'hui c'est
celui d'un encerclement progressif par
des corps intermédiaires et des milieux
très disparate de la présidence trump
savait d'ailleurs souvenez-vous
guillaume en un mot commencé bien avant
son élection
lorsqu'une partie des républicains
notamment les ex néoconservateurs façon
robert cagan était monté au front contre
lui donc il ya une partie de
l'establishment républicain qui ne l'a
jamais admis
je ne sais pas si ils ont tort ou raison
en tout cas le fait est là et
aujourd'hui il me semble que l'étau se
resserre autour de trump ce que je vois
moi personnellement c'est une présidence
qui progressivement va être un gulliver
empêcher le 6 mai moi je pense que la
question de la plainte pour viol est un
point essentiel parce qu'aujourd'hui le
phénomène mi temps contre rob moore le
contrôleur le candidat républicain parce
qu'aujourd'hui le phénomène dit tout est
un phénomène il est pas seulement
américains il est mondial et que sur ce
sujet là on voit bien que ça va
concerner à mon avis le comportement
individuel de chaque représentant de
chaque personnalité politique donc ça
peut être un vrai séisme
et je suis d'accord avec renaud girard
sur le fait que c'est sans doute ça qui
l'emportait par rapport à la question du
projet après on peut dire que sur cette
question-là du comportement le sujet de
donald trump est aussi à quelque chose
d'essentiel
parce que donald trump est quelqu'un qui
ne se comporte pas comme un président
américain
parce que quelque part ses incartades et
sa manière de ne pas être politiquement
correct lui a permis d'être élu mais
qu'on peut se demander si ça lui
permettra de durer
je voudrais là-dessus rebondir sur les
questions écologiques après tout c'est
mon fonds de commerce
je pense que ce qui se passe aux etats
unis sur la question du climat avec
cette mobilisation à la fois de
personnalités comme bill gates de grands
entrepreneurs de la société civile
darty
hollywood et c'est très intéressant
parce que quelque part il ya dans la
société américaine des ressorts de
contre-pouvoir et une capacité à faire
un twist a changé à se transformer qu'en
france on n'imagine pas parce que nous
sommes une société peut être plus plus
rigide ou qu'il ya plus d'inertie
donc je pense que pour donald trump
c'est mal parti à l'avenir et c'est sans
doute pas à cause du projet politique
mais plutôt à cause du comportement et
de sa manière de ne pas être un vrai
président et aussi d'être venu
encourager quelqu'un qui était quand
même extrêmement contestée il a pris un
risque en considérant sans doute que les
attaques sexuelles et mick mais amy tous
étaient pas aussi important que ça
l'était c'est quelque chose de très
politique et c'est ce que nous dit à
l'internaute sur lefigaro.fr comme henri
moura qu'il puisse se présenter avec
toutes ces accusations pourquoi ne
s'est-il pas retiré il ya eu des
pressions sur lui mais il a refusé
donald trump tardivement d'ailleurs
tardivement pardon a choisi de le
soutenir
vous parliez d'écologie ou si je mets
des biens parlons-en vous avec
l'histoire des loups alors ça vous
paraît peut-être un peu anecdotique
à mon avis c'est intéressant le
gouvernement vient de sortir un plan
d'action pour le loup 2018 2023 les
luganais de plus en plus en france
au dernier comptage on serait à 360 et
donc la question c'est est ce qu'il faut
en tuer mais parce que les loups ces
carnivores et les loups auraient tué dix
mille brebis et moutons divers l'année
dernière et donc il ya polémique pour
savoir ce qu'il faut prélever comme on
dit aujourd'hui plus de loups on en
prévoit de temps tu 40 l'année prochaine
c'est trop disent les écologistes c'est
pas assez disent les éleveurs et bien
est-ce que vous avez un point de vue là
dessus
renaud girard mais moi je trouve pour
que les écologie ne se penche pas sur
les brebis
pourquoi est ce qu'ils préfèrent les ou
aux brebis
moi j'aime bien la fontaine alors je
suis un peu du côté de l'agneau de la
brebis et le pastoralisme et d'une veste
au réalisme voilà donc ça très étonnant
d'avoir cette espèce de la d'affection
pour pour le lou parce qu'en fait le
loup aime bien égorger les brebis mais
pour le plaisir parce qu'ils les mangent
pas tout ne se passe et 10000 parce que
sinon
ce serait des groupes voilà donc ccc et
donc je comprends très bien
ces bergers si vous voulez qu'ils
protègent leurs brebis et qui ne veulent
pas que iliad et nous comme ça voilà
alors est ce que on peut en garder
quelques oui quelques quelques spécimens
pourquoi pas mais je me demande si les
écologistes demain où certains
écologistes je suis pour l'air pur dans
les villes qu'on soit bien clair pour
moi c'est ça l'écologie est important
c'est plus de parts plus de diesel plus
de particules fines
c'est ça qui est important pour ça que
je suis pour le nucléaire parce que je
suis écologique maintenant mais
l'avocate
je suis pour le nucléaire parce que
j'aime bien les purs en deux ans au look
vous êtes contre les jambons qui nous
vient d'allemagne les particules fines
qui nous vient d'allemagne mais j'ai
peur qu'ensuite on va on va vouloir
protéger des vipères par exemple parce
que là des pères est en danger et c'est
donc
donc je trouve effectivement qu un
abattage des noirs je ne sais pas là
c'est encore une question technique
combien l'ambiance plus supporter de
loups cissé 200-250 c'est en tout cas je
pense que la population des loups ne
doit pas croître dans nos campagnes
certainement pas non plus six mais allez
vous défendre le grand méchant loup
écoutez je trouve que c'est une
discussion qui est d'abord culturel
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
j'irai jusqu'au xxème siècle où était
vraiment l'espèce musique par définition
il y aurait jamais eu une discussion sur
faut-il l'abattre ou pas selon la
battait et donc je trouve que renaud
girard est un peu un homme du 19e siècle
c'est pour
pour pour le calcul mais nous
discuterons de sa ensuite mais je pense
que ce qui est important c'est qu'à
partir d'un certain moment au fond au
milieu du xxème siècle on est passé
d'une espèce totalement nuisible à
l'idée que c'était une espèce en voie
d'extinction et donc en fait cette
espèce de changement de statut rend les
choses compliquées surtout quand par
ailleurs on veut préserver effectivement
la possibilité d'élever d'élever les
brebis qui est quelque chose qui
préserve également la biodiversité donc
on est dans une espèce de conflit
d'intérêts et puis ce qui est très
important aussi c'est que vous avez
l'impression qu'il faut tout de suite
choisir se choisir son camp c'est à dire
que si vous dites qu'il faut qu'il faut
garder des loups vous êtes contre les
brebis et vous êtes contre les éleveurs
et si vous dites que vous trouvez qu'il
faut garder les troupeaux vous êtes
contre les écologistes
donc moi je trouve que ce qui est
important là dedans c'est au fond de
proportions gardées et le plan loup de
nicolas hulot est intéressant parce
qu'il fixe ont fait une espèce de quota
sur l'idée qu'on peut aller jusqu'à 10%
en fait jamais de 10 % ont des papiers
parce que tu essaies pago donc sur le
pays mais ce que je trouve très
intéressant dans la période actuelle
c'est qu'enfin on s'engage sur un débat
alors que ce que je voulais dire c'est
que quand on s'intéresse à la question
du loup on découvre que c'est un sujet
sur lequel il ya énormément de paranoïa
de secret on sait même pas exactement le
nombre de loups qu'il ya en france on ne
le dit pas publiquement de peur que les
éleveurs se dresse contre vous donc
c'est un sujet presque romanesque et sur
lequel on est à la fois donc dans le
culturel dans l'économique et dans
l'idée qu'une profession ne doit pas
être persécutés on aime le loup d'autant
plus qu'on est un habitant des villes et
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut que le
gouvernement essaie de faire en sorte
d'arbitré positivement pour les éleveurs
je reprend la parole cher
car nous accueillons valentin pilote
plateau âge indifférent mais je suis je
m'accroche à mon siège valentin haüy
brin d'espoir est trop trop rapide vous
avez interrogé vous êtes allés plutôt
vous êtes penché sur les réseaux sociaux
et en fait on aime bien les loups sur
internet
oui on aime beaucoup les loups j'ai posé
la question sur twitter nos internautes
faut-il laisser vivre les loups la
réponse à l'éclair voilà ce qu'on m'a
répondu tout à l'heure la question ne
devrait même pas se poser
oui nous divisent laine ou bien sûr nos
dikaba bon voilà au delà de ces réponses
c'est simple on a aux euros sur twitter
toujours qui nous signale que en
régulant chaque année le nombre ça
pourrait être intéressant de voir ce
qu'on peut faire
en fait c'est déjà le cas donc à 10% par
an elle signalé avec cet arrêté mi
interministériel ministérielle de
juillet mais nos internautes en fait un
exemple qui revient en boucle c'est le
cas de l'italie alors pourquoi l'italie
je vais vous expliquer en italie les
bergers ont le même phénomène nous 17
internautes du figaro.fr
on va le voir dans un instant alors
comment font-ils
c'est très simple il ferme
leurs moutons dans des enclos et les
fonds surveillés par des chiens qui
peuvent garder un oeil en l'occurrence
sur sur ces dernières on a encore paul
sur lefigaro.fr qui nous dit que c'est
quand même bizarre que du côté italien
le sujet du loup soit si peu évoquée
alors que pourtant les loups la base
sont bien plus nombreux on peut pas
vérifier les chiffres mais apparemment
c'est le cas et c'est le cas ils le sont
bien plus si damas constate que la
cohabitation se passe très bien en
italie à des lieues de kiss de ce qui
pourrait se passer en france en france
d'une part beaucoup de bergers sont
devenus fainéants et cet internaute
c'est assez marrant il parle de son
voisin en l'occurrence qui hébergeait et
qui nous signale que il surveille mal
ses troupeaux qu'il deviendrait
apparemment fainéants et qu'ils ne
lèveraient plus des chiens en
l'occurrence qui pourrait monter la
garde contre les loups
chez lui le mot de la fin un argument
recevable seulement le mot de la fin
il ira à cet internaute qui nous signale
que les bergers devront s'adapter à
l'espace sauvage qui n'est pas un espace
destiné naturellement à l'élevage
merci adélaïde zulfikarpasic ya déjà eu
des sondages concernant ce que les
français pensent et non ça ne me dit
rien en revanche ce qui est intéressant
sur la position des internautes
notamment des gens qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux ça relance que disait le
succès parce que en général les gens qui
expriment sur les réseaux sociaux et
notamment sur twitter ce sont plutôt des
gens qui ont un profil jeunes urbains
citadins voilà ce n'est pas très
surprenant
après il n'y a pas eu de sondages mais
je pense qu'on retrouverait
effectivement cette espèce de
d'antagonisme entre ce que les français
ils sont à la fois attachée à l'écologie
et en même temps ils ont une bonne image
des éleveurs a donc peut-être qu'on
pourrait ne pas les opposer élevage et
loup mais honnêtement dont je connais
pas la réponse à la question un joli
commentaire d'aurélien sur twitter qui
nous disent que je colle il ya des loups
à quatre pattes et d'autres à 2 dès
qu'elle parle et vous est bien plutôt de
ceux à quatre pattes chers aurélien
alexis lacroix vous allez avoir le mot
de la fin
mais vous avez 15 secondes parce
qu'ensuite on rend l'antenne ça va être
dur alors sur sur les loups je pense
qu'il faut pas antagonisent et les
bergers j'aime les vergers moi je ne me
présente pas comme vous dans une
circonscription électorale des pyrénées
atlantiques
mais je vous pourrez et j'aurais leurs
suffrages mais néanmoins envoyé cette
idée de tuer des loups m pour moi elle
est absurde et donc le maximum à mon
avis qu on peut admettre et qu'on peut
autoriser pour cette liquidation
je crois que c'est le plan hulot mais si
on allait au delà si on cédait aux
demandes des bergers dont je comprends
par ailleurs les inquiétudes
on serait dans une folie car cette
réintroduction du loup et je rejoins
totalement ce qu'a dit lucile elle va
dans le sens de la restauration de cette
espèce de continuum qui a existé
longtemps entre les hommes et ces bêtes
là qui sont après tout des bêtes de
l'entourage là pour le coup on est très
loin des autres exemples que vous
preniez ça n'a rien à voir avec des
anguilles ou je ne sais quel
hyper ou je ne sais quel animal sordide
il ya une amitié il ya eu historiquement
une haine activités du une amitié de
l'homme et du loup et s'est il tout
simplement cela que peut-être sur un
mode carnavalesque on a ressuscité mais
maintenant faut en tirer les
conséquences et avoir un esprit de
responsabilité
merci beaucoup pour ce magnifique pleine
noyer prolos merci à tous les cas ça
tous les cinq d'avoir été là et surtout
aux charges d'internautes rester
connectés dans quelques instants vous
retrouver dans l'émission condensation
jean-rené vander plaetse funky et le
directeur délégué de la rédaction du
figaro magazine et surtout le dernier
lauréat du prix interallié pour un très
beau livre très beau livre il s'agit de
l'honneur
alexis lacroix la nostalgie de l'honneur
et nous rendons l'antenne pour laisser
la place à jean rené
[Musique]